pues muy buenas noches lo cierto es que
aquí en el centro de la ciudad de miami
los exteriores de donde en pocos minutos
va a arrancar este foro público está
creciendo la tensión de hecho la policía
había preparado un dispositivo especial
para lo que pudiera pasar y ya se ha
empezado a desplegar varios equipos de
antidisturbios por lo menos hay cuatro
personas detenidas y entre él ha habido
pues pequeños enfrentamientos entre los
simpatizantes de donald trump y de joe
biden se espera que en poco menos de 30
minutos llegue la caravana presidencial
con donald trump para participar en ese
foro público aquí en florida un estado
clave para
y poder ganar las elecciones y es que ya
lo dicen los expertos políticos
quien gane florida va a ganar las
elecciones presidenciales
anthony vamos hasta el otro lado de esta
contienda por la presidencia de eeuu
vamos ahora al acto de byd en que se
espera para este acto y como transcurre
de momento todo parentemente está en
calma en fila donde va a participar el
candidato demócrata se espera que en
este tanto en el foro público de aquí de
miami como en el de joe biden se puedan
abordar aquellos temas que no se
pudieron y que no se han podido abordar
en este segundo debate presidencial que
estaba previsto aquí en la ciudad de
miami por lo pronto lo que comentaba en
algunos de los presentes aquí es la
inmigración en la salud y también la
economía a las puertas de esa crisis
financiera que va a venir después de que
se pueda superar la pandemia de
coronavirus así es antoni gracias por
toda la información por supuesto muy
pendientes lo que ocurre en estos dos
actos en eeuu gracias y buena noche